l'opievoy bientôt en passe de
disparaître le second plus gros bailleur
social de france est aujourd'hui victime
de la loi allure l'obligeant à être
rattachés à une collectivité locale
unique au 31 décembre 2016 problème
valérie pécresse présidente de la région
ile de france a annoncé le 18 février
dernier qu'elle ne reprendrait pas la
structure à sa charge le rôle de la
région c'est d' impulser une politique
d'aidé par exemple les franciliens qui
le souhaitent et qui le peuvent à
devenir propriétaires d'impulser une
véritable politique du logement en
cofinançant du parc locatif social
l'ambition la région n'est pas de
devenir de constituer un patrimoine
immobilier
autre argument avancé par la région la
dette de l'opi voix s'élevant à un
milliard d'euros
avec 58 logements étalé sur huit
départements et pas moins de dix sept
mille cinq cents logements dans les
yvelines
l'avenir incertain du bailleur social
inquiète les locataires pourquoi pas se
doter d'un outil de 80 mille locataires
c'est je comprends pas d'un côté en
favorise les regroupements
intercommunaux favorise des grosses
structures les hyper structure et une
superstructure comme pouvait l'être au
pouvoir ont la casse le président de
l'ot pivois pierre bédier n'ayant pas
souhaité s'exprimer sur le sujet a
annoncé lors de ses voeux que la masse
salariale ne serait pas réduite en
septembre dernier pierre bédier
également président du conseil
départemental des yvelines avait
envisagé la création d'un office
interdépartemental avec l'essonne pour
reprendre les hlm
le 8 mars prochain l'avenir du bailleur
devrait être tranchée en conseil
d'administration